hey guys Pete here so this is gonna be
the shortest twin peaks' video I ever
made but it has a specific purpose so I
was working on the 10 things you might
have missed video today and I started
thinking about a couple different rabbit
holes I was going down at the time I was
thinking about the tool buzz and the
doppelgangers and if there's a
difference and whatever and I thought
about all the unfinished stuff that's in
the return right now season 3 and I was
thinking like what are my three biggest
questions what are the three things that
I would like to have answered in the
finales coming up this weekend the
number three is important here because
there's literally so many of them but we
know we're not gonna get answers to
everything and if I just say one well
that's a little bit hard to so three
seem like the right fit and the reason
I'm putting this video up is because I
want to hear from you guys what your
three things are only three but at least
three at the same time all right so
three of the mysteries they could be big
ones they could be small ones you could
skip over ones you think we're obviously
gonna find out the answers to but give
it a thought and let me know I'm pretty
sure on two of mine but I don't think I
have a third one yet I don't think I've
settled on it yet I have a lot of them
you know me but I don't think I've
settled down on the final third one but
then this weekend after I put out the
other video on Saturday or something
I'll put out a preview and all the
responses will give us something to talk
about because we know it's pretty much a
fool's errand to try to guess in what's
gonna actually happen in the episode but
we got to do something because we only
have one installment left all right so
thanks for watching give it a like leave
your three mysteries that you want to
see solved what would be the most
satisfying ones for you you know we're
not gonna get answers to everything but
what would be the most satisfying most
perfect way for this thing to end for
you and yeah let me know thanks for
watching guys I'll talk to you soon